>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Jackie Kookesh:
I'm Jackie Kookesh.
I work for Sealaska Heritage
Institute, which is --
the mission is to perpetuate
and provide cross-cultural
communication
between Alaska Native
Haida, Tsimshian,
and the Tlingit people
of Southeast Alaska.
And our program is based
on community building --
using our culture and community
to provide a school readiness
and early literacy program for
birth to five years of age.
We have a video clip
we'd like to play.
[ Beating Drums ]
>> Speaker 2: In 2014, Sealaska
Heritage launched Baby Raven
Reads, an early literacy program
for Alaska Native families
with children up to age five.
The goal is to promote school
readiness, language development,
and early literacy because
research shows that children
who are fluent readers by the
end of third grade are likely
to do well in school and
go on to higher education.
Research also has
shown the effectiveness
of using culturally relevant
teaching resources and methods
to improve academic achievement
in indigenous students.
Through the program, Sealaska
Heritage sponsors monthly
culturally based family events
designed by elders, parents,
and cultural specialists.
At the events, students are
immersed in traditional stories
and practices
in an intergenerational
Alaska Native community set
in a traditional clan house.
There, students develop
a love of learning
through community and culture.
Baby Raven families
also receive free books,
which are distributed
at the events and mailed
to families regularly.
The program also funded
production of new,
culturally based
children's books
that reflect the Alaska
Native world view.
And as of 2017, Sealaska
Heritage had produced nearly 20
books through the program.
Nine more books will be
published through 2020.
This is groundbreaking
because prior
to the Baby Raven Reads program,
only a few culturally
relevant children's books
from Southeast Alaska existed.
And in recent years,
schools have come under fire
for using materials that
depict native cultures
and histories inaccurately,
creating a disconnect
for native students.
The program also
allowed Sealaska Heritage
to develop culturally relevant
posters, which were distributed
to schools and libraries
throughout Southeast Alaska.
Since its inception, nearly
200 Alaska Native families have
enrolled in the program.
And a study by Juneau's
McDowell Group in 2016 found,
among other things, that 68%
of Baby Raven Reads respondents
observed a significant
improvement in vocabulary.
The study also found
that, on average,
children in the Baby Raven Reads
program were read to 160 minutes
in a typical week, compared
to children not in the program
who were read to an
average of 120 minutes.
"The program has had a profound
effect on enrolled students,"
said a parent whose child
participated in the program.
She was quoted in a
recent news article.
Quote: "My daughter picked
up the books and said
to her little brother,
let me read these to you.
I know that I didn't teach
her those letters or sounds.
That's this program.
The impact is huge and
it's a joy to watch."
Funding for the Juneau based
pilot program ended in 2017.
And that year, Sealaska
Heritage received a second grant
to continue Baby Raven Reads
for another three years
and to take the program to
nine additional communities
throughout Southeast Alaska.
In 2017, the program
was nominated
by the American Indian
Library Association
for its American Indian
Youth Literature Award.
The association will
announce winners in 2018.
For more information
about Baby Raven Reads
and Sealaska Heritage
Institute's other programs,
see www.sealaskaheritage.org.
[ Beating Drums ]
>> Jackie Kookesh: We're
really proud of this program.
it was a three year
pilot program in Juneau,
Alaska and the impact,
as the video suggests,
is over 200 families
in the Juneau area.
What makes it unique and
what I challenge my education
department staff to look
at was: How are we going
to build a school readiness
early literacy program that's
rooted in place,
rooted in community,
is culturally relevant,
and responsive?
And we didn't have
to look too far.
We had to just look back at
ourselves as native people
of Southeast Alaska and look
at our core values and look
at our own belief
system and look at our --
use our cultural lens in
designing our program.
Engaging family.
Engaging our own rich
history of oral tradition.
As you see in some of the books,
they are taking our Raven
stories and our mythology
and re -- kind of
repackaging them for children.
And also using the
family monthly events,
where we bring community
together,
where we bring families and
the children to the clan house
in the tradition
of our ancestors
where community came together in
the clan house and told stories
from our elders and
children listened.
So adding that piece of
developing 20 children's books
and bringing -- and making that
more accessible to everybody
in Juneau and in the region.
So if you get a chance, we
brought some books with us.
They're hot off the press.
We're pretty excited about that.
The other piece that I guess
I want to focus on is to share
with you that any programs
you design need to be designed
in the community to be relevant
to the population
you're serving there.
We're here to answer
any questions.
We love this program
-- Baby Raven Reads.
And I thank you so much again.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.